bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo avec pour
m'accompagner ou moracchini bonjour
michael moore à tous et dans l'actualité
bien après deux semaines après avoir
avoué qu'il détenait bien compte en
suisse
jérôme cahuzac est sorti de son silence
il reconnaît une faute morale
démissionne de son mandat de député
l'ancien ministre évoque sa part dont
vous êtes folle erreur qui l'a suivi
durant 20 ans le bal des patrimoines est
ouvert on sait désormais tout ce que
possèdent les membres du gouvernement
leur maison leur compte bancaire jusqu'à
leur vélo
les députés de leur côté rechignent ils
ne veulent pas que leur patrimoine se
retrouvent sur la place publique
l'assemblée nationale en pleine
effervescence avec l'examen en deuxième
lecture du texte sur le mariage
le vote aura lieu mardi prochain des
incidents dans l'hémicycle et dans la
rue les manifestations sont de plus en
plus nombreuses
le climat se radicalise avec nous pour
commenter l'actualité alain vidalis
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
un poste qui n'est pas de tout repos en
ce moment une nuit blanche par exemple
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi des
députés des parlementaires qui ne
veulent pas publier leur patrimoine
c'est un ministère difficile en ce
moment c'est un ministre connaît pas
toujours l'activité mais qui est
extrêmement intense dès que vous voyez
qu'il ya des hésitations ou des
questions qui peuvent se poser dans la
machine gouvernementale on est très
souvent au coeur du sujet alors c'est la
règle dans cette émission nous sommes
allés aux quatre colonnes tendre notre
micro à quelques uns de vos ex confrères
députés voici ce que ça donne c'est
quelqu'un de discret mais des kz2 tout à
fait disponible
moi j'ai découvert un homme extrêmement
professionnelle
connaisseur et qui fait du bien je crois
au travail parlementaire donc chapeau
alain vidalies ce qui m'attendait à ce
qu'un vieux routier l'assemblée comme
vous dites quelqu'un qui connaît bien
ici le fonctionnement de l'assemblée
nationale qui était très longtemps
députés fassent mieux cet équilibre
entre les droits du gouvernement les
droits de l'assemblée nationale de la
majorité et l'opposition et je trouve
qu'il a un peu de mal parfois à trouver
ce point d'équilibré il gagnerait à
mieux défendre les droits du parlement
et les droits de l'opposition très malin
très patient et
je pense qu'il s'il n'était pas là
aujourd'hui il y aurait beaucoup plus de
tensions entre le parlement et
l'exécutif
moi je le trouve un peu fermé je le
trouve un peu trop partisan pour établir
véritablement le lien mais on a affaire
un homme qui est vraiment trop
doctrinaire pour pouvoir être le lien
entre le parlement et le gouvernement
pour des compléments des compliments et
des critiques
c'est un peu un peu la règle pour
quelqu'un qui a été si longtemps député
vous défendez pas assez les droits des
parlementaires dit daniel fasquelle vous
êtes passés de l'autre côté du numéro un
je comprends cette cette critique parce
qu'elle repose sur une conception qu'un
peut-être un peu différente de ce qu'est
le ministre des relations avec le
parlement
c'est pas un poste de médiateur
c'est un beau jeu défend une politique
et j'ai d'ailleurs créé sous
j'appartiens au gouvernement avec cette
particularité c'est probablement pour ça
quand on m'a confié cette mission
d'avoir aussi j'essaie de le faire le
mieux possible bon d'avoir aussi ce lien
avec l'opposition que n'ont pas
forcément tous les tous les autres
ministres mais j'ai voulu dès le départ
ne ne pas être je dirais une sorte
simplement de correspondants du
gouvernement je vais positif que se pose
c'est peut-être le poste le plus
politique des ministres
c'est évidemment pas juste passé le plus
politique mais c'est un post très
politique d'ailleurs c'est le seul
ministère qui est des rattaché
directement au premier ministre et donc
le quotidien dans ce ministère là c'est
travailler tous les jours pratiquement
en permanence vous êtes en lien avec le
premier ministre ont régulièrement tous
les jours bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr et
pas utiliser la politique évidemment
rien oui être l'écho du parlement on
travaillait beaucoup avec la majorité
ce double aspect et puis un aspect que
pas connue mais
vous qui suivez le l'assemblée mais
c'est vrai au sénat j'ai amené à
remplacer très souvent les ministres une
sorte de douzième homme un peu
polyvalent mais c'est parfois au pied
levé c'est une partie difficile mais
aussi intéressante dans la tâche allez
on va passer au lundi puisque vous êtes
ministre et vous avez participé à cette
opération
on va l'appeler opération transparence
mais c'est un drôle de la vie pour les
ministres en fin de journée sur un site
internet les français au plus examiné le
patrimoine de chacun des ministres le
détail avec jérémy hartmann
il était attendu un peu plus tôt dans la
journée mais les internautes curieux
auront finalement dû patienter jusqu à
18h10 avant de découvrir le site de tous
les fantasmes
les déclarations de patrimoine des
ministres accessible à l'adresse
www.desjardins.com patrimoine point
gouvernement.fr voici donc à quoi
ressemble la déclaration patrimoniale
d'un ministre un tableau sur fond blanc
avec plusieurs chapitres comme les
comptes bancaires les immeubles bâtis et
non bâtis les assurances vie ou les
biens mobiliers divers des tableaux dans
lesquels on peut lire pêle-mêle que
michèle delaunay possède une longue
liste de vingt-trois compte en banque
que christiane taubira est l'heureuse
propriétaire de trois vélos et que
laurent fabius est à découverte de 30000
716 euros sur l'un de ces trois comptes
bancaires
mais le total de chaque patrimoine n'est
pas affichée en bas de page
il faut donc faire le calcul soi-même
pour apprendre par exemple que jean marc
ayrault a déclaré un patrimoine net de 1
million cinq cent cinquante mille euros
il n'ya pas non plus de tableau
récapitulatif de l'ensemble des 38
ministres
une présentation qui cherche à éviter
tout comparatif car la crainte de
l'exécutif et de voir apparaître un
palmarès des ministres des plus riches
aux plus pauvres mais puisque l'info est
désormais accessible
on peut vous le dire c'est laurent
fabius ministre des affaires étrangères
qui a déclaré le patrimoine le plus
important du gouvernement
ou alors la vie d'alice voilà c'est fait
est ce que la démocratie se porte
beaucoup mieux après avoir déclaré son
patrimoine
je dirais pas beaucoup mieux mais je
pense que c'est une sorte de passage
obligé quel est le problème
faut être conscient mais pour nous comme
pour la droite républicaine
il ya une suspicion qui existe dans la
population sur ce que sont les élus sur
ce qu'ils font le manque de confiance
mais je pense que c'est plus grave c'est
c'est vraiment de la suspicion quant on
connaît bien ce milieu quand on a envie
y ont constaté donc tous les sondages
pratiquement aujourd'hui que 75 80 % des
gens ont une mauvaise image ou pense que
les même carrément que les gens que les
gens sont corrompus et s'entraîne que la
parole et des politiques elle même est
décrédibilisé c'est à dire que on est
dans la situation où ça va rien changer
pour l'action du gouvernement mais on a
besoin aujourd'hui de retrouver non pas
la confiance dans notre politique mais
dans un premier temps la conf dire que
ça va changer donc c'est symbolique
finances ne sais pas ce que je dis si
avait compris ça je me suis mal exprimé
c'est c'est vraiment très important
c'est pas pour défendre notre politique
c'est pour redonner du crédit et pour
lever la suspicion qui existent
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de nous mais comme
vis-à-vis de tous les élus la france est
aujourd'hui très affecté par cela et
donc ce que veut faire le président de
la république c'est répondre
on peut penser que les français ont tort
on peut se dire m'enfin pourquoi il
pense ça puisque nous on essaye de vivre
normalement mais mais c'est la réalité
et pourquoi attendre la sphère cahuzac
on aurait pu se dire que françois
hollande
vous l'avez dit hiller le cutter healy à
11 mois quand il est arrivé au pouvoir
mais parce que il ya eu je vous
comprenez bien que 7,7 rien laquelle
jacques 7 7bis besoin de transparence
personne ne peut dire aujourd'hui une
affaire comme ça ne met pas en exergue
la question de la transparence des modes
de vie des élus alors sais pas je ne
suis pas d'accord avec vous c'est pas
cette opération la vie en baisse rsa le
document que vous avez des commentaires
ni zaria pas d'addition et c'est pas un
document fait pour cette affaire-là ce
ce qu'ont à amblie c'est le document qui
existe déjà
car les élus font des déclarations
publiques et ans l'a rendu public et on
l'actualiser mais il est présenté
exactement 2
même façon que ceux qu'on a remis et qui
était jusqu'à présent secret un peu
aussi quand même dans la transparence
magna est d'accord peut pas un peu trop
tu pas d'accord on peut pas dire tout et
son contraire je dire si on n'avait rien
fait vous seriez en train de dire mais
enfin quand même c'est gras vous
comprenez vous reprendriez mef rassemble
dix ans mais la suspicion des français
que vous répondez à quoi quand on
s'engage et c'est ce que c'est le
message du président de la république
c'est pas une idée une conception si les
français avaient une autre image au fond
ça change rien de se connaît simplement
comme nous on sait que se connaît en
fait ignoré par les parler français ou
qu'ils ont une image qui est différente
de ce qu'on ne se connaît où tout ce
qu'on essaie d'être dans tous les cas et
bien la transparence elle répond à ça
pour qu'après la parole politique puisse
être reçus elle n'est pas reçue
aujourd'hui suivra la vie d'alice tout
le monde n'est pas forcément d'accord
avec vous à passer au mardi et après la
discipline des mini ça ne vous a pas
échappé il y à la rébellion des députés
s'étaient annoncés par françois hollande
le choc de moralisation passera aussi
par la publication du patrimoine des
parlementaires mais on ce mardi à
l'assemblée une partie des députés y
compris socialistes montrent dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée
comme une heure et dix ans cette
perspective jean baptiste daoulas
c'était mercredi dernier françois
hollande fait une annonce choc sur le
patrimoine des politiques
les déclarations de patrimoine seront
rendus publics pour tous les membres du
gouvernement
elles le seront pour les parlementaires
une fois le projet de loi adopté les
ministres se sont exécutés lundi mais
les parlementaires traînent des pieds
à commencer par le groupe socialiste la
plupart des députés ps ne veulent pas
avoir à décider eux-mêmes de publier
leur patrimoine
nous pensons qu'une haute autorité
indépendante va est nommé de mal gérer
ses déclarations de patrimoine
c'est à elle qu'il appartiendra de
définir les modalités de la
misy la publicité de ces déclarations en
clair rien ne dit que le patrimoine des
parlementaires sera publié depuis une
semaine
claude bartolone mène la fronde contre
le projet de françois hollande pour le
plus grand bonheur de l'opposition
claude bartolone a dit avant le week-end
la publication du patrimoine ne sert à
rien si jérôme cahuzac était aujourd'hui
au gouvernement ça qu'un c'est qu'il
n'aurait pas publié les informations qui
finalement ont causé le scandale et son
départ du gouvernement
quand claude bartelone prend la pose la
position qui est de s'opposer à la
publication des patrimoines ce n'est pas
la position des députés ump c'est une
des positions qui est très largement
partagé un front bartelone jacob lagarde
inédit pourtant chaque groupe la firme
il ne s'agit pas d'une réaction
corporatiste alors vous avez réussi un
petit tour de force en mettent d'accord
claude bartolone et christian jacob le
projet de loi sera en conseil des
ministres mercredi
il ya même de fortes chances que les
députés ne votent pas cette partie klaus
est que comment allez-vous faire d'abord
je voudrais remarqué dans la qualité de
votre émission parce que jusqu'à présent
je me demandais quelle était la position
de l'ump sur cette question nous avions
plusieurs fois interrogé monsieur jacob
si j'ai bien compris à extrapoler ces
ces propos parce qu'il ya quelques
quelques mois si j'ai bien compris ils
sont hostiles et tiercé c'est important
comme informations y sont hostiles
attendez la position de l'ump jusqu'à
présent il commenté les différentes
positions des autres là si j'ai bien
compris monsieur lagarde est contre et
qui s'exprimait je suppose pour son
parti où son groupe
d'accord l'envi et monsieur jacob et
contre aussi sensible enregistre aussi
non mais j'enregistre deuxièmement
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on
fait des déclarations il ya une
commission de la transparence qui
existent au bo cette commission n'a
aucun pouvoir et notamment pas celui de
pouvoir saisir l'administration fiscale
pour procéder à des vérifications dans
le projet de loi qui sera
présenté en conseil des ministres
mercredi nous allons donc créer une
haute autorité pour la vie publique et
cette haute autorité va recevoir des
pouvoirs d'investigation c'est pour
répondre à votre observation sur la
sphère cahuzac ars et le manque
d'investigation qui qui pose un problème
car pouvoir de contrôle pouvoir de
contrôle elle va recevoir les
déclarations qu'elle reçoit aujourd'hui
qui sont peut-être même plus précises -
sur les règles appliquées deuxièmement
un pouvoir de contrôle sur le contenu
un pouvoir d'investigation c'est à dire
que l'administration fiscale et les
banques devront fournir à cette haute
autorité à l'ensemble des ensembles sur
effectivement ce volet renforcement des
mesures de contrôle
mais la publication il n'en veut pas qu
est ce que vous allez faire de cette
obligation de publication et patrimoine
et les élus que vous avez proclamé de
françois hollande a annoncé que le
président de la république a annoncé et
nous allons donc quand le texte viendra
en débat discuter non pas du principe
mais mais des modalités de l'autorité
qui va décider
pas du tout pas du tout je ne sais pas
s'agit pas sur cette question qui est
importante de renvoyer la solution à une
autorité indépendante la solution semble
important du sein de la solution est
politique et sera où la publicité ou une
publicité sous une forme différente que
celle qui a été faite d'une manière un
peu abrupte pour les pour l'aider pour
les membres du gouvernement mais on
restera attaché possible en son sens que
non non non la puissance heures de spa
publication souscrit pas du tout à vos
propos la décision est prise de le faire
on n'a pas les modalités pour nous on a
fait tout seul là il s'agit des
parlementaires on va quand même avoir un
dialogue avec eux je ne sais pas à moi
quelles sont les solutions alternatives
qui sont possibles qui sont acceptables
dans tous les cas sur le principe on
reste sur la démarche qui a été voulu
par le président de la république
alors puisqu'on parle de transparence à
la vie d'alice pourquoi ne pas
s'attaquer aussi à la cagnotte de la
réserve parlementaire 150 millions
d'euros pour certains et bien c'est une
affaire de clientélisme pour d'autres au
contraire une aide aux acteurs locaux
vous
les vins les avis sont partagés maclean
de bélanger faut-il supprimer la réserve
parlementaire
cette cagnotte est attribué chaque année
aux députés et sénateurs qui la
redistribue ensuite sur leur territoire
au sénat les avis sont partagés pour
beaucoup ce système est d'abord une aide
pour les acteurs locaux
ça me permet d'aider les associations et
puis lorsqu'une commune a besoin d'une
aide je la donne ce qui me reste n'est
pas si important que cela donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi on aurait besoin de
supprimer ça aussi la réserve coûte
chaque année 150 millions d'euros à
l'état 90 millions vont aux députés 60
millions aux sénateurs mais plusieurs
problèmes sont pointés du doigt
l'inéquité des dotations entre les élus
le manque de transparence et l'aspect
clientéliste du système
récemment le sénateur philippe marini
s'est fait épingler pour avoir largement
financé avec cette somme le centre
équestre de sa ville de compiègne je
vois pas de quel droit parlementaire
peut avoir une somme dont il dispose
librement pour financer tel ou tel type
d'opération j'ai demandé plusieurs fois
que ce soit attribuée de façon
égalitaire entre tous les parlementaires
sans fin sans distinction d'appartenance
à commission d'ancienneté et autres vous
convient d'y arriver dans ce cas les
frais d'autres plaident pour une réforme
du système c'est le cas de jean louis
masson
le sénateur de la moselle a présenté une
proposition de loi visant à rendre
publique l'utilisation de cette réserve
lorsqu'un sénateur par exemple s'en met
plein les poches
par le biais d'une association bidon
dire comme ça serait publié tout le
monde saurait que l'intéressé a agi de
manière malhonnête et automatiquement et
bien il y aurait des poursuites
judiciaires à son encontre
la disparition de la réserve
parlementaire pourrait être une mesure
de la prochaine loi de finances qui sera
examiné au parlement à l'automne
prochain
alors il ya une semaine pierre moscovici
1000 et des finances il dit il faut
réformer tout cela ça ne peut pas rester
en l'état et si on comprend bien et bien
le gouvernement ne touchera pas la
réserve parlementaire c'est bien ça y'a
raison alors c'est d'abord vrai ça
parce que oui c'était à peu près ça
parce que quelle est la question sur la
réserve parlementaire d'abord le
gouvernement ne souhaite pas prendre la
décision unilatéralement
c'est une question qui concerne le
parlement deuxièmement la réponse c'est
la tranche est-ce qu'il faut supprimer
la réserve parlementaire
il ya beaucoup de fantasmes autour de
cette affaire en réalité sur le terrain
les associations les petites communes
souvent pour elle c'est peu de chose en
milliers d'euros financière c'est une
série à me sauver les gens donc il ya
tout un discours une fantasmes autour de
ça quelle est la réponse ou pour éviter
ces problèmes vous le supprimer mais on
vous supprimer en même temps l'utilité
donc je pense que la question d'un autre
côté il ya quelques dérives
il ya eu des dérives il y en a encore je
pense que ce monsieur marini avait sont
mignons quand même ça surprend tout le
monde y compris les gens qui ont
l'habitude donc quelle est la réponse
que tout ce public c'est de l'argent
public
déjà à écouter les gens pensent que je
pars que c'est une cagnotte c'est
l'argent que c'est raymond le député qui
fait un chèque c'est rien de tout ça
l'argent il passe par le trésor public
qui devrait il va jamais sur les
conduits là aussi le transparent sur le
montant ce qu'a fait claude bartolone à
l'assemblée est remarquable on l'a on
l'a pas dit parfois on met avant quand
vous étiez députés de l'opposition vous
aviez une petite somme toute
transparence sur les montants de l'écrit
but et par le sénat moi je suis
il me semble que j'avais beaucoup de
choses mais nous je pense que la réponse
là c'est pareil on voit bien qu'il ya
des voies les articles de presse et je
sais 90% ça correspond pas à la réalité
vous avez montré un sénateur kyl il faut
changer tout ça enfin j'espère que nos
parents c'est parce qu'il est en conflit
avec un sénateur voisin qui ils accusent
c'est une affaire judiciaire dont je
veux pas aller au delà
non vraiment c'est un problème très
articulé transparence les gens il faut
qu'ils sachent combien on reçoit et à
qui on le donne et à partir de là je
parce que ça posera aucun problème est
qu'en plus ça continuera à rendre les
services qui sont rendus aujourd'hui
donc je crois que effectivement le
président de l'assemblée le président du
sénat sont sur cette ligne là juste un
mot rapide qu'est ce que c'est important
sur les conflits d'intérêt dans le
projet de loi toujours présenté mardi en
conseil des ministres y aura-t-il la
liste des métiers incompatible avec le
mandat de parlementaire
on a deux solutions aujourd'hui qui sont
à l'étude qui seront finalisées dans le
projet de loi
il ya d'une part il existe déjà des
métiers que vous pouvez pas exercer pour
telle ou telle raison du code électoral
il ya une liste
est-ce qu'il faut ajouter d'autres et
est-ce qu'un ajoutant d'autres on peut
finalement répondre à ce qu'est notre
préoccupation
donc aucune patience n'est pas
d'empêcher les gens qui ont un métier
avant et notamment de vendre c'est un
métier dans une activité libérale ou un
péché un agriculteur de faire sur terre
comme concret au peut être avocat et
avec l affaire prend un exemple non vous
prenez l'exemple
le problème et qui a été posé qui a été
posée pourquoi parce que effectivement
tout le monde sait qu'on pouvait à un
moment donné être le chef de
l'opposition parlementaire et dans un
grand cabinet d'affaires avec tout ce
que s'il y aura cette liste parce
qu'effectivement on ne veut plus que
l'activité de conseil puisse être
exercée en même temps que l'activité
d'avocat mais il se trouve que vous avez
des gens qui sans avocat je peux
témoigner et qui n'ont jamais été dans
ce type de dossier parce qu'ils font du
droit du droit des gens non c'est nous
qui allons décider mais parce qu'on est
en train d'expertiser d'une manière
définitive ce qu'on peut faire ou ce
qu'on va faire on est sur la ligne jaune
du point de vue constitutionnel et vous
avez deux entrées possibles dans le
raisonnement soit traitée par métier
soit éventuellement pistes alternatives
aujourd'hui de traiter sa part le niveau
de revenus complémentaires que vous
pouvez en tirer des premières seuil
si vous dites vous pouvez continuer à
travaux cas mais à condition de ne pas
gagner
tant par mois je pense que vous avez
réglé la question de la distinction
entre les avocats d'affaires télécentres
allez on continue à mardi toujours 18h
interview télé de jérôme cahuzac que
l'on n'avait pas ni vu ni entendu depuis
la passation de pouvoirs à bercy le 20
mars dernier
entre temps il ya eu les aveux d'un
compte en suisse la colère des
socialistes et surtout la colère des
français
avec quels mots l'ex-ministre du budget
revient-il mardi soir ivan relaie
l'information ne semblait guère
surprenante presque d'entrée de jeu ce
soir
jérôme cahuzac le confirme il renonce à
son mandat
aujourd'hui en conscience j'estime que
la gravité de cette foot ne me permet
pas de rester parlementaire dans une
interview très minimaliste sans cravate
l'ancien ministre du budget est venu
pour un tout autre exercice de
communication présenté ses excuses
non seulement j'aurais pu mais j'aurais
dû dire non et j'ai commis une faute en
acceptant ce poste
chaque mot semble avoir été choisi avec
soin parmi ceux qui reviennent le plus
souvent sur un registre très personnelle
barde ombre faute morale
fall erreur dans l'écrasante majorité
des cas qui se sont présentés lorsque
j'avais à prendre les décisions
je ne sais plus que j'ai cela je vais
tellement occulter que je me mens à moi
même avant de mentir aux autres mais
l'ancien ministre est aussi venu
organiser sa défense face aux rumeurs
les sommes que vous venez d'évoquer
n'ont rien à voir avec la réalité et la
procédure judiciaire le montreur
pourquoi est-ce qu'on devrait vous
croire aujourd'hui c'est bientôt mon
problème pourquoi me croire aujourd'hui
dès lors que l'on a cru à tort
hier c'est la justice qui me permettra
de démontrer à vous aux autres que ce
que je dis maintenant est la vérité
autre démenti
aucun membre du gouvernement n'aurait eu
vent de son implication
qu'est-ce que d'autres savaient ce que
le président savait j'ignore quel était
son degré de connaissance de 7
faire ce que je veux dire c'est que lui
comme au premier ministre comme un
pierre moscovici
je n'ai pas dit la vérité difficile de
mesurer les effets de cette déclaration
le ministre confirme en revanche que
cette affaire marque bel et bien la fin
de sa carrière politique
jean marc ayrault a dit que c'était une
opération comme et qu'il n'avait pas
regardé jusqu'au bout vous allez
regarder
j'ai regardé jusqu'au bout mais j'ai
partagé ses sentiments mais d'abord
c'était très tôt je trouve pas à pas aux
événements et c'est pas ces images là
qui est à l' accent de sincérité selon
vous souhaitez pas là je suis pas je
suis pas juge c'est le juge qui
maintenant il est plus dans le milieu
politique il a rendez vous avec le juge
pas avait pas avec les politiques et
l'assemblée nationale vous étiez à un
mètre de lui
voilà voilà vous savez donc qui va dire
l'assemblée nationale dans la vie il ya
des images comme ça pour vous pour moi
que vous garderez tout fuit et il y en a
pas beaucoup
peut-être ce moment là moi je crois que
je le garderai toujours au moment où je
vous parle j'ai seront regard et je suis
à omettre de lui il est à côté de moi
quand il se lève pour répondre je suis à
côté
et quand on le connaît ensuite monsieur
moi quand un homme se lève par la
représentation nationale pour dire avec
cette force là j'ai jamais une compte
j'ai cette image là est ce que j'ai
entendu
l'opération de communication m'enlève
pas cette image
évidemment cette petite phrase relevée
par par l'opposition j'ignore quel était
le degré de connaissance de cette
affaire de françois hollande il aurait
pu peut-être plus catégorique
jérôme cahuzac ils auraient pu le régler
je leur envoie ses responsables jeudi
seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est que il
est démissionné de son poste de député
j'ajoute j'ajoute quand même il ya eu
des affaires sur lesquelles puisque on
est ici au parlement
il ya une réponse ya la justice mme il
ya aussi les des commissions d enquête
parlementaire
quand on a voulu en faire une sur l'
affaire des sondages on a refusé
d'accord
vous avez dit jérôme cahuzac a
démissionné de son poste de député on a
évidemment été recueilli quelques
réactions l'assemblée je vous propose de
les écouter
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il a pris la
bonne décision à la fois pour respecter
à l'assemblée nationale et la démocratie
est à la fois pour se respecter lui-même
je crois que compte tenu du caractère
combattants de jérôme cahuzac
c'était la seule position qu'il pouvait
prendre à la fois pour être confronté à
la justice à ses juges
et puis pour reconstruire sa vie donc le
certainement pas lui dire merci au lieu
de ne pas revenir à l'assemblée
nationale je pense que c'est la moindre
des choses et surtout le droit aurait dû
l'empêcher de parvenir à l'assemblée le
droit est ce qu'il faut un nouveau texte
pour empêcher un député qui a été mise
en examen ou qui ont cerné par une
affaire de revenir dans le principe je
serais assez d'accord sauf que regarder
les choses juridiquement là c'est parce
qu'il a avoué qu on sait que
effectivement il a commis les faits
sinon c'est une fois que la condamnation
est définitive
jusqu'à jusqu'à nouvel ordre
quelqu'un qui serait mise en examen si
et si après il ay des relaxes et vous
faites comment s'esquisse un pic pour le
gouvernement pour le gouvernement c'est
une règle et c'est normal parce que peut
pas y avoir la suspicion dans l'activité
des parlementaires
c'est un peu plus et un peu plus délicat
quand même parce que vous allez passer
ensuite à quoi à tel ou tel
fonctionnaire qui peut abandonner être
poursuivi ou ou si lyon cherche des
ennuis un des journalistes j'aime aussi
les immunités quand on est parlementaire
qu'on peut aussi s'en servir face à la
justice
quelle unité unité parlementaire mais
vous pensez aujourd'hui qu' il n'y a pas
une justice à part pour les
parlementaires
monsieur cahuzac va être jugé c'est les
juges d'instruction les mêmes que pour
vous que pour n'importe quelle personne
l'immunité parlementaire
c'est uniquement aujourd'hui la
nécessité pour le juge de demander
l'autorisation du bureau pour le mettre
en prison c'est pas
bovidés éviter des condamnations c'est
tout ça n'existe pas enfin que au moins
que notre conversation serveurs aussi
sur ce point là à faire la transparence
et sur le fait qu'on est bien dans le
droit commun donc on reste solide et
qu'un député mis en examen peut
continuer à exercer son mandat renazé
condamné mais oui parce que quand vous
êtes mis en examen vous n'êtes pas
forcément coupable alors vous parlais
tout à l'heure dans 4 cette semaine
pierre moscovici a été entendu par la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
sur cette affaire à sa gauche était
assis le président de la commission
l'ump gilles carrez suis pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière était allé à
bercy après la publication d'un article
de valeurs actuelles
le ministre de l'économie at-il tout
tenté pour savoir la vérité après les
révélations de mediapart il a répondu
devant la commission ce qui l'a répété
plusieurs fois dans les hémicycles de
l'assemblée et du sénat
j'affirme ici je répondrai à vos
questions bien sûr que dans le cas du
droit existant encore une fois nous
avons fait tout notre devoir est que
nous avons fait plus que n'importe qui
avant nous qui ici ne reprochera d'avoir
respecté le droit et ses présomptions
j'espère personnes alors il devrait
normalement y avoir une commission d'
enquête parlementaire ce sera décidé
mercredi dans l'hémicycle vous êtes jean
comme claude bartolone comme le premier
ministre pour cette commission denquête
oui mais c'est une décision qui fait
honneur à notre démocratie les parulines
demandées par l'ue dei
ça fait honneur je pense au gouvernement
et et au groupe socialiste qui est
majoritaire parce que c'est une rupture
complète avec ce qui se passait ces
dernières années il ya eu deux affaires
par exemple importante la sphère des
sondages de l'elysée c'est pas rien la
réaction qu'on a eu c'est à dire
l'action qu'à la droite aujourd'hui elle
est bien normal ça a été de demander une
commission denquête refusé karachi enfin
extrêmement limité c'est à dire que j'ai
été aussi refusé pour l'essentiel bon là
on nous demande une commission denquête
et là contrairement à karachi cette
commission enquête aura accès à la
résolution la résolution qui va être
votée à l'assemblée nationale est une
résolution sur la qui a été votée à
l'unanimité sur laquelle tout le monde
est d'accord parce que le le texte il
donne le spectre du travail c'est celui
de la résolution ce que faisait la
droite avant 10 heures on veut bien mais
à la fin il y avait tellement peu de
choses dans la résolution que ça
devenait impossible
nous avons changé et c'est le même débat
que celui que nous avons eu le
changement la transparence le président
de la république était évidemment
d'accord il sera large
il sera transparent et ça sera public et
tous les responsables ils ont répondu
sous serment
ça va durer sur tellement un petit peu
de temps on n'est pas près de tournai le
volet cayzac
vous n'êtes pas prêt à tourner la page
finalement c'est une sorte de star ac va
vous coller pendant des années mais
personne ne peut nier que c'est une
affaire grave qui a créé un vrai
traumatisme
nous sommes des responsables publics
politiques et le président de la
république en annonçant toutes ces
initiatives les groupes socialistes en
disant oui à la commission denquête
s'est mis à la hauteur de l'événement et
je pense que de ce point de vue là on
peut accepter les comparaisons avec ce
qui se passait précédent dames où le
bilan pour l'exécutif de cette page qui
a usé qui n'est pas bon vous avez vu les
sondages il est c'est naturel je veux
dire c'est quelqu'un que nous avons
choisie à qui on a fait confiance et
aujourd'hui les gens découvrent qu'on
s'est trompé et nous on découvre qu il
nous a trompés et donc on n'apporte de
réponses en termes de transparence si de
cette épreuve il peut sortir
je dirais une amélioration du vivre
collectif et notamment de vives bien
collectif et notamment sur la question
de la transparence alors je pense qu'on
aura une réaction de responsables
politiques à voix basse et à tout autre
chose à la vie d'alice on passe au
mercredi et les syndicats qui
manifestent devant le palais du
luxembourg
c'est un débat sous tension au sénat qui
examine la loi de sécurisation de
l'emploi cette loi c'est la
transcription de l'accord qu'il y avait
il ya quelques mois entre les syndicats
manifestations hostiles à l'extérieur
mais contestation aussi à l'intérieur
notamment du parti communiste regarder
en musique et en ordre de bataille
aux portes de la haute assemblée avant
son examen en séance les sénateurs
communistes s'unissent tôt syndicats
opposés à l'accord sur la sécurisation
de l'emploi c'est la ds et la précarité
dans le collimateur des élus communistes
le dispositif qui permet aux entreprises
de négocier le temps de travail avec les
salariés c'est à dire la possibilité
d'un chantage patronal pour dire aux
salariés
vous devez baisser vos salaires vous
devez changer vos conditions de travail
vous vous devez accepter de la mobilité
forcée
sinon on licencie la pression dans la
rue et la bataille qui se poursuit dans
l'hémicycle les sénateurs communistes
demandant en vain la suspension des
débats pour protester contre le peu de
temps accordé à l'examen du projet de
loi
le vote final devrait intervenir
vendredi ou samedi alors vous vous posez
vos questions nos questions le débat
continue mais on a vu qu'à gauche
évidemment cette loi avait beaucoup de
mal à passer même à l'assemblée
nationale où il ya eu au parti
socialiste des gens qui se sont abstenus
mais parce que ça correspond aussi une
division une division syndicale
c'est d'abord le résultat d'une méthode
président de la république avait dit
devant les france présentant devant les
français je vais choisir la démocratie
sociale et il avait dit nous ferons le
pari des accords majoritaires notamment
dans l'est notamment dans les
entreprises c'est à dire que là où sont
les syndicats à travers eux on pourra
faire évoluer les choses
on a pendant des semaines dit que cet
accord était au fond minoritaires enfin
qu'ils étaient majoritaires mais qu' il
correspondait pas sept et trois
organisations sur cinq mais qui
correspond de 15 salariés
on a appris que c'était faux donc on a
un accord qui est un accord majoritaire
et donc il ya des syndicats qui
représentent une majorité de salariés
qui n'ont
et d'autres voient dans cet accord
démolition ne sais quoi du coût du
travail qui l'accord medef
aujourd'hui si vous voulez faire un
licenciement économique à l'absence de
ce texte qui décide et seule une
entreprise
demain il y aura que deux solutions
possibles soit avec le contrôle de
l'administration
c'est à dire dans l'inspection du
travail soit après à d'accord
majoritaire dans l'entreprise c'est à
dire que les salariés auront accepté le
plan social est ce que c'est ce qui
aujourd'hui sont dans la rue et qui
disent ah mais non mais c'est à dire
c'est une amélioration on pourrait
toujours dire interdire les
licenciements il ya aussi la corée du
nord mais ça fait pas rêver
donc je pense que ce texte il est le
résultat d'un compromis et ça se voit
sibilité aussi du temps de travail la
mobilité géographique tout ça aussi et
mis en cause vous qui est très un ancien
avocat spécial et du droit du travail le
connaissent tout ça par cas mais vous
connaissez aussi les griefs qui peuvent
aller avec mes enfants d'abord j'observe
que la cgt très en pointe grands
syndicats la cgt et en même temps dans
le presque le même moment où dans la rue
et 17 c est un scandale
il ya un accord qui a été signé chez
renault y compris y compris par la part
la cgt dire que les salariés qui sont là
y compris de ce syndicat décidé de le
faire évidemment un accord de mobilité
ni bon qu'est-ce qui se passe enfin
c'est 50% des salariés qui doivent êtres
qui doivent être contents donc on donne
des droits aux gens sur leur propre vie
alors bien sûr on dit toujours oui mais
dans ce contexte parfois ils ne pourront
pas faire autrement
enfin le savez j'ai beaucoup plaidé les
des licenciements et je me suis toujours
demandé si c'était le mieux pour moi
deux ans trois ans après ça m'est arrivé
souvent de remettre un chèque à des gens
que plus tôt il est gardé leur boulot
trois ans avant c'est ça c'est ça la
question
je préfère vous dire que la réponse
n'est pas si évidente que ça juste un
mot non pas aux avocats et aux ministres
en ce moment c'est le sénat le siège de
la contestation dans tous les textes que
vous faites passer non c'est pas le
siège de la contestation je pense que il
poursuit pardon souvent c'est parce que
la situation politique est complètement
différente
je suis très étonné ça fait depuis que
je suis arrivé alors le mauff avant de
dire je les ai que garder d'ailleurs je
les collectionne
j'aurai fini c'est un livre que dira la
sphère du couac aux affaires du poids
qu'au sénat dire franchement les
journalistes n'ont que des qualités il
est remarquable mais alors là je les
hais ces collectors évidemment on n'a
pas à chaque fois qu'on perd couacs au
sénat mais on n'a pas de majorité
comment voulez vous qu'on fasse il faut
qu'on arrive à convaincre et le groupe
communisme je lui reprochais les combats
reprocher à des gens ne pas avoir tenu
des engagements qui n'ont pas pris ils
ont décidé de majorité pardon ils sont
dans votre majorité ou pas il a une
mission pas dans la majorité
gouvernementale vous avez quand même
remarquer d'affaires moyen d'administrer
liste et donc c'est normal ils ont voulu
cette liberté donc ils n'ont pas
d'engagement et ils sont dans la
majorité sénatoriale qui s'est
constituée parce que c'est une majorité
contre la droite et donc que les choses
sont très claires et je dois dire que
bon je trouve ça au début j'étais un peu
étonné à force de dire que maintenant je
suis sur mon but j'ai un bug renoncer et
je collectionne pour en faire un
chapitre quoi voilà d'accord allez on va
revenir à l'assemblée avec le jeudi le
mariage pour tous qui continuent à
enflammer les esprits 25 heures de débat
pour le texte sur le mariage pour tous
et le temps programmé fixé pour cette
seconde lecture à l'assemblée et dans la
dernière ligne droite dans la nuit de
jeudi à vendredi vous y étiez bien sûr
on a même failli en venir aux mains
elisa bertolo mais on a bien cru que ça
ne finirait jamais au bout de la nuit
les députés ump sont contraints au
silence faute de temps de parole encore
disponibles scène ubuesque
tous doivent écouter claude bartolone
égrainer la liste des amendements a voté
sans pouvoir les défendre un amendement
identique
41 90 129 150 283 une fin de soirée en
apothéose
quelques heures plus tôt comme tous les
soirs depuis le début des discussions
les militantes mariage pour tous se
mobilisent au moment de la dispersion
quelques fauteurs de trouble se mêle au
groupe
la manifestation se termine avec une
prière de rue avant une dispersion par
les crs
bilan une ballerine égard et qui
resurgit quelques instants plus tard
dans l'hémicycle
mais vous savez ce que j'ai trouvé mois
sur les invalides une ballerine
messieurs et mesdames mais les
parlementaires une ballerine
voilà ce que les forces de l'ordre de
monsieur valls aujourd'hui font ils
interpellent des jeunes de france avec
des ballerines voilà et vous êtes fiers
de ce que vous faites des attaques de
l'opposition qui font sourire des
conseillers de christiane taubira
les esprits sont fatigués le mp provoque
un violent incident de séance la
provocation à l'égard des militants la
province où la provocation à l'égard des
députés de l'opposition la provocation
elle vient un distille diablement de la
part du gouvernement et la majorité
la de tous ses excès claude bartelone
décide d'en finir et de poursuivre les
débats toute la nuit une nuit longue
très longue pour certains les débats se
sont terminées à 7h30 ce matin
le vote solennel aura lieu mardi
prochain dans l'hémicycle alors alain
vidalis là encore vous étiez aux
premières loges
vous étiez quelques petits incidents on
a vu on va regarder une photo prise par
un député dans l'hémicycle et le réflexe
au moment de l'incident dont vous étiez
juste à côté il ya eu pendant pendant
ces 25 heures aussi quelques phrases
malheureuses un député ump qui a dit
qu'avec ce texte on assassinait nos
enfants vous savez ce qu'on vous
reproche on vous reproche d'avoir un
petit peu attisé la colère
en choisissant le temps programmé en
avançant le calendrier qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça le texte a été voté
au sénat lorsque vendredi matin le texte
a été voté au sénat ce qui n'était pas
pour une avance puisque vous avez entre
3 et 8 voile avance donc il fallait que
ce soit fait et ça a été fait dans de
telles conditions que les
article 1 et 3 c'est-à-dire les articles
essentiels de ce texte ont été voté
conforme
vous le savez mais je précise que quand
l'assemblée a voté un article et le
sénat le même il n'est plus en
discussion et donc on se trouvait à
partir de vendredi avec un texte où il
n'y avait plus en discussions font que
des artistes je vais pas dire secondaire
mais un peu quand même c'est à dire que
les socialistes le 16 mai si vous pouvez
accélérer voilà donc on décide en
décident d'accélérer pourquoi très
honnêtement parce que ce cette condition
est remplie il y à une crispation autour
de cette affaire et puis ce qui se passe
dans la rue les gens le droit de
manifestation je serai le toujours le
premier à le défendre l'acquis ne
pensions pas aujourd'hui autour de genre
qui manifestent normalement se sont
greffés des groupuscules d'extrême
droite une radicalisation et qui à
chaque fois est à l'origine des débats
de définir ville dans ses cinq ans et ça
vous dit il valait mieux en finir vite
je pense qu'il fallait avoir un double
message au triple même 1
le débat est finie sur l'essentiel 2 il
faut que les responsables publics
aujourd'hui montre où doit avoir lieu le
débat c'est une affaire de fonds
pourquoi au fond je vais dire des choses
un peu basique mais pourquoi on a
inventé la démocratie
pourquoi fuyaient la guerre civile c'est
à dire qu'on peut s'affronter
il ya des règles il ya des élections il
ya des règles il ya une majorité il ya
une minorité mais on se tape pas dessus
c'est pour ça que les incidents de ce
point de vue là sont une régression tout
à fait inacceptable et donc le message
c'est au parlement
les gens qui sont contre et qui
manifestent mais on leur demande pas de
partir du moment où ce sera la loi de la
france ils devront l'appliquer
ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont pour ça
veut dire qu'ils devront se battre
politiquement pour peut-être un jour
voté autres je n'en crois rien mais la
rue leur liberté à eux et leur combat ça
doit être celui-là ce doit être de créer
des dégâts dans les incidents
et quand monsieur fasquelle et 10 des
forces de l'ordre de monsieur de
monsieur valls non c'est les forces de
l'ordre de la république
la ville a vite pour clore ce chapitre
six mois moins d'une minute des missions
on dit que le premier mariage pourrait
être célébré des bijoux à ses vrais ou
par oui non oui c'est une information on
va terminer sur cette information aussi
on a appris vendre
10 matin les otages qu'ils avaient été
pris au cameroun une famille de sept
personnes avec des enfants quatre
enfants ont été libérés
c'est le soulagement j'imagine de votre
côté soit en tout cas ce qu'a dit le
président de la république
c'est plus que le soulagement voilà il
ya des moments comme ça dans la vie ces
images à vous comme un mois nous ont
choqués d'image de ses enfants
et puis et puis la crainte cette famille
et est au milieu de la tourmente de la
ville de la vie politique en vue sur les
conditions non puis je ne suis pas
informé donc mais voilà un petit moment
de bonheur grand bonheur pour cette
famille et pour
et puis j'espère un petit bonheur
politique collectif pour la france et on
ajoute que lundi il y aura dans
l'hémicycle à l'assemblée à un vote sur
la poursuite du conflit au mali comme le
veut la constitution et ce sera
également au sénat c'est un débat
obligatoire au bout de quatre mois donc
il faut fouiller ce vote et je pense le
faire un point sur la situation sur
l'association aussi d'être transparent
et je pense aussi à un moment de
consensus républicain
merci beaucoup a la vida vivement
participé à notre émission merci
beaucoup même si on se retrouve la
semaine